today we're connecting all evidence in
my hear academia
that heavily indicates deku will get all
for one
this video will also elaborate on the
final fate of shigaraki at the end of
the series
which has been hinted at by hirokoshi
during a few interviews
i'm so confident in the core of this
theory that right now i'm making a
turtle quirk guarantee
that by the end of this video you'll
agree with me that midoriya will get
all for one just before we get into it
there will be spoilers ahead for those
of you who don't read the manga
so proceed with caution if you don't
want to know anything
that happens after season 4. also
today's video is sponsored by our
friends at crunchyroll
who are offering a 14-day free trial of
their premium membership
if you go to crunchyroll.com turtlequirk
with attack on titan starting again
pretty soon and jujitsu kaizen currently
airing
it has never been a better time to get
crunchyroll premium
the episodes arrive on the site
literally one hour
after airing in japan and they're
professionally subtitled
not to mention accessible on all smart
devices
these past few months i've personally
been using crunchyroll on my ps4
and i've caught up on a ton of series
including parts 1 to 5 of jojo's
season 1 of mob psycho 100 and i'm
currently checking out jjk
every friday many of you already know i
used it to catch up on black clover
earlier this year
which is now one of my favorite series
so definitely give crunchyroll a try
if you're looking for more anime to
explore there are three different
premium tiers you can choose from
and your free trial will be valid for
any of them meaning you can pick the
ultimate fan tier and you know get
unlimited downloads of any anime you
want
like i said you can access everything
i've mentioned and more
by going to crunchyroll.com and getting
your two-week free trial
now to kick off this theory let's start
with how deku is going to get all for
one
and to do that i'm going to explain some
important context that you need to
listen to
even if you're fully caught up with the
manga in chapter 287
afo revealed a crucial piece of
information about quirks
which is that every quirk in this series
contains a copy of its user's
consciousness
one for all has the quirks of its
previous users stored inside it
and their consciousness manifests as the
famous vestiges
like afo deku can visit his vestige
world if he's asleep or
in some kind of temporary trance and
he's able to use their quirks
when he's awake granted he's only used
black whip and float as of making this
video
but the point i'm making is that you
know by the end of the series deco will
use
all the quirks inside one for all now
ask yourself exactly how one for all is
storing these quirks of the previous
users
we know that with all for one he can
straight up steal people's quirks by
using the hole in his hand
i mean he was just born that way and
it's never changed one fraule
is not a naturally occurring quirk so
what aspect of it
enables this quirk storage in case you
may have forgotten
one full is the combination of two
totally different powers
and it's crucial that we look at them
separately to understand
how deku will get all for one the first
power belonged to afo's brother
and it was a pretty pointless ability
that i'm sure you're aware of
the quirk could be transferred to
someone else if he wanted the transfer
to happen
and if someone consumed a piece of his
dna that was it it was just a quirk that
could be transferred
in the present day that means three
things for one for all
number one one full can be transferred
as we know
number two the user has to want the
transfer to happen
and number three it means that someone
has to consume the user's dna
to receive one for all we can clearly
see how the transfer quirk affects one
for all
however obviously oneful has way more
abilities than just what i've mentioned
it has the vestiges it has the quirks of
the previous users
and it has the immense power that has
built up over the generations
those abilities are not the result of
the transfer quirk as we can see
but rather the power stalker quirk that
all for one gave to his brother
it was previously believed that the
power stalker was only good for building
up physical strength
after all allmight went his entire hero
career
only using the strength of one for all
he never manifested any additional
quirks like blackwhip for example
it was only in chapter 213 that we began
to understand that the power stalker
did more than just store up physical
strength instead
it would also store up the quirk factor
of the quirks that it came into contact
with
which is why the quirk of each user is
inside one for all
with that context out of the way let's
get into how midoriya will get all for
one
and then i'll explain the fate of
shigaraki to begin
afo himself held the power stalker quirk
for an
unknown period of time before
transferring it to his brother
i'll repeat that afo had the power
stalker quirk in his body
before his brother before nanashimura
and obviously before midoriya
he was the first person to have it
besides the original user
from everything we've already
established the power stalker absorbs
the quirk of anyone it's transferred to
and the first person it was ever
transferred to was
afo whilst he was never a user of one
for all
he had the part of one for all that
stores the quirk of you know the people
who have it
what the power stalker does is duplicate
the quirks that it comes into contact
with
leaving them totally unaware that their
quirk has been copied
and this is actually supported by
something almighty said in chapter 217
as well as the fact that quirk
duplication is a very common thing in
this universe
if you're a manga reader you've seen it
a million times by this point
in almight's opinion his master
nanashimura
didn't know one fraud contained the
quirks of previous users
if that belief is accurate then it
confirms the power stocker duplicates
quirks
rather than steals quirks and here's why
nana shimura gave one for all
to almight when he was in middle school
if one for all had
stolen her quirk from her then float
would have disappeared alongside one for
all
sure she would have had the embers of
one floor for a while just like
almighty did but the flame dies out
eventually and it certainly would not
have
lasted the four years between this
moment when she gave it to him
and her death what i'm saying is that
when the flames of one fall died out
she still retained her original float
quirk just like afo
retained his original all for one quirk
all my statement confirms this
because nana shimura didn't even know
that her own quirk was stored inside one
for all
clearly if it took her quirk then she'd
obviously be aware of that because she
wouldn't have it anymore
the fact she wasn't aware that quirks
were being stored indicates that there's
a duplicate version of her float quirk
rather than the original therefore
bringing it back to afo now
his all for one quirk must have been
copied by the power stalker
just like everyone else who has had this
power in their body
once you have it it copies your quirk
that's the way it's operated for all the
users of one for all
and that's how it would have operated
for all for one as well he then gave the
power stalker to his brother
completely unaware and of course this
created one for all
which means at the very core of one for
all seemingly unknown to everybody
is all for one it exists in the core of
one for all
this has been foreshadowed several times
when looking back
for example bakugou referred to deku as
being the same as all for one
and then on the next page we got this
panel which
literally speaks for itself just look at
what deku says here
this point was again foreshadowed later
in chapter
285 when all might discovers something
about one fraud that he doesn't want to
speculate
which is then followed by a flashback of
bakago
saying that one for all is the same as
all for one
additionally we've had two big moments
that show a psychic connection between
deku
and all for one the first was during the
joint training arc
and basically deku was super hyped to
start his match against class 1b
and this was then followed by of one in
prison who claimed that he could now
hear
his little brother's voice the very next
chapter
deku activated blackwhip for the first
time and that is obviously not a
coincidence
midoriya unlocks the first of his new
quirks the chapter
immediately after afo just randomly
hears his brother's voice
clearly there is some sort of connection
something weird going on there
the second psychic moment happened
during the war arc
in which as soon as shigaraki received
the all for one quirk
the vestige of the first user appeared
to deku
and just told midoriya to stop shigaraki
how did he even know that shiguraki had
awoken at that moment
the answer is that the core of one for
all already contained all for one
which explains the psychic connection he
was aware of shiguraki getting the all
for one quirk
moving on though remember how the fifth
user said
that all the quirks inside one for all
have been building up
alongside the quirk itself well all for
one was the first quark to be inside one
for all technically speaking
which means it's been growing in power
ever since the beginning
this provides the ultimate setup for the
end game for deku to unlock all for one
but like a
supercharged version of the quark that
we've never seen before and hopefully
overpower shigaraki in the process
but just before we get into shiguraki's
fate we need to talk about the two
missing vestiges of one for all there is
at least one vestige
for all of the previous users of one for
all what there isn't though is a vestige
for all for one himself
and there is no vestige for the original
user for the power stalker quirk
i don't think that they're the two
vestiges that are currently
shadows and i have a few reasons for
thinking this number one is that they
were never holders of one for all
so if that's them there then the order
is just totally messed up
for example all might would really be
the sixth user of one for all
rather than the eighth despite having
the kanji for eight in his name
and similarly deku would be the seventh
user despite having the kanji for nine
in his name
i don't think horikoshi would fumble
like this and mess up the orders of the
one floor users
so i i don't think that these two
characters here are
all for one and the power stalker person
instead i think it's safe to assume
that these two vestiges are hidden
inside the core of one for all
after the power stock emerged with the
transfer quirk
the fifth user did say that deku would
be the one to complete one for
all at face value that means that he's
gonna unlock all the quirks of the
previous users
but once he's completed one for all that
is probably when it would be appropriate
for the all for one reveal to happen and
to you know get the uh
the look inside the core of one for all
and we see afo
and the power stalker vestige it's
possible that deku and the other
vestiges
will have to defeat all for one inside
the vestige world
and if they win that battle then deku
gains control over his quirk
let me know your thoughts on that theory
and also where you think the afo vestige
is do you think it just disappeared
after the power stalker merged with the
transfer quirk
or do you think like i do that off one's
vestige is literally inside the core one
for all
and so it's kind of hidden away turning
our attention to shigaraki now
in an interview with toho cinema
magazine in 2018
hirokoshi hinted at something of
interest the interviewer asked him if
shiguraki was a villain
that should be saved and hari replied by
saying yes
i think so i think we've gotten to the
point where shiguraki
can no longer turn back though if i say
more i feel like it'll dampen your
imagination
so i won't explain in detail this is
harikoshi admitting two years ago
that he would like shigaraki to be saved
but in his opinion shigaraki has just
gone too far at this point
bearing in mind what he said in this
interview it's relevant to now see that
during the war arc
despite everything that's happened so
far despite everything shigaraki has
done
deku still tried to save him from being
absorbed by all for one
which in my opinion is a big indicator
of how the end game of this series is
going to play out
midoriya is incapable of intentionally
killing shigaraki
his actions in the vestige world prove
this to me beyond a reasonable doubt
at the same time to not kill shiguraki
at the end of the series
would mean that he'd always be a threat
and someone who could possibly return at
any time
even if deku was to use all for one and
one for all
to take shiguraki's quirks the fact
remains that you know shiki has a body
that is so powerful it's near all my
levels of strength
and that's even without any quirks so if
you take his quirks he's still
just as strong the only way to truly
neutralize shiguraki without killing him
is to strip him of all power not just
his quirks
but his physical enhancements as well in
a different interview
hirokoshi mentioned how the story of
mahir academia would culminate with all
characters coming together in the final
arc
including one very important character
that was introduced during the
internship arc which is the overall arc
i've said it many times that this
character
is obviously eerie and what if
in some sort of attempt to help deku
erie
rewind shigaraki back into tenko shimura
harukoshi said that tomorrow sugaraki
had reached a point of no return
but as we should all know by now
tomorrow and tenko could not be more
different in their ideologies
when i looked into the meaning of
tenko's name the first part means to
change
and the last part meant arc him changing
back
into tenko during the final arc loosely
fits the meaning of the name tenko
if eri was to rewind him then the threat
of shiguraki would disappear because his
bodily enhancements would all go
and tenko would have the chance to get a
do-over in life
without the influence of afo naturally
this theory only works if shiguraki's
memories are also rewound
and you know what the only person we've
ever seen erie rewind
this far back was her dad and he he
ceased to exist
so perhaps when she does these big
rewinds people's memories are also
rewound with it
we just don't know because there's no
living character who has suffered that
big of a rewind before
horukoshi has confirmed erie's
importance for the final arc
and we also know that deku lacks the
intent to kill shigaraki
we also know that deku wants to save
everyone and by turning shiguraki back
into tenko
you've saved someone who had a pretty
terrible life all because of this evil
guy who was obsessed
with his grandma and obsessed with his
family and tracked him down and raised
him to be a villain
and at the same time it wasn't just all
for one who failed shigaraki
he was walking along the streets and not
a single person or a single hero
came to actually help him so he's been
failed
on all counts so to get this chance to
have a do-over in life
start from ground zero it's a nice way
to avoid
deku killing someone that he pretty much
has to kill to uh
to resolve everything um and yeah you
know it's within aries powers she's done
this before she's rewound someone
this far back before so listen it's
possible
that was my theory on how deku will get
all for one
and how the endgame of my academia might
play out
be sure to hit that subscribe button for
more content like this
and until the next one peace out